- [Instructor] What I
want you to do is evaluate
the expression 5x squared
when x is equal to three.
Pause this video and have a go at that.
All right, well, we just have to think
about every place we see an x,
we'll now replace it with a three.
So this is going to be
equivalent to five times,
instead of x squared,
it's going to be five times three squared.
And we know from order of operations,
we do the exponents first.
That's why I actually put a parentheses
around the three squared
to just make that clear.
And three squared is,
of course, equal to nine
and five times nine is equal to 45.
Let's do another example
that's a little bit different.
Let's say I have the expression 1/3
times six to the x power,
and I want to evaluate it
when x is equal to two.
Pause the video again and
see if you can work that out.
Well, once again, everywhere
where we see an x,
we'll replace that with a two.
So this is going to be the same thing
as 1/3 times six squared.
Where we saw the x, we now
replace that with a two.
And so this is going to be equal to,
we do the exponent first,
order of operations,
so it's going to be 1/3
times six squared is 36,
and 1/3 of 36 is equal to 12.
And we're done!